PLAYING LOOSE AND FREE DOWN THE
STRETCH, YOUR REFEREES ARE E SA
STEPPING N'T PLAY ENOUGH
INTO THE CORNER. LIKE THE OTHER
THEY HAVE SEEN ITS SHARTHROUGH.
NOW BJORKFROM THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE, 12 TO BE EXACT
AGAINST ANYBODY IN THE LEAGUE,
WELL, IT CAN GO AGAINST YOU,
GIVE THESE GUYS A
MAKES IT   Brian: DID HE NEED T
GOAL, OR WHAT?
AN INCREDIBLY LONG DROUGHT FOR
HIM, A GUY THAT
BACK
WINGER NEEDS A GOAL REALLY
BADLY.
HE DOESN'T TAKE THE SHOT, , D N
TO POINT  AND
AND THEY START TO ADDED UP AS
THE GAME  TO HIM.
BECAUSE THERE ARE TWO GUYS
THERE, THAT MEANS THEY AR
KUCHEROV, ONE TIME BACK INTO
THE NET .WHEN
McDONAGH GETS IT  LOOK AT
McDONAGH WITH HIS HEAD UP .PAUL
AND ENDS UP WITH SERGACHEV, A B
DID THIS STAMKOS LINE NEVER
POURED OUT, THEY GOT THE LINE,I
HE CUTS DOWN THE OPTIONS. LONG
WH
ROSS COLTON!
HE TAKES THE
KNOCKED BACK INTO THE CORNER.
>> Brian: WHAT A SHOT BY ELLIOT
POINT-BLANK AND NOW BACK AWTNIN
BACK DOWN WITH A BEAUTIFUL PUCK
MANAGEMENT . HERE IS STAMKOS
OFF
AND STAMKOS NOW, DEEPEN A
CORNER.
BACK TO KUCHEROV. PENALTY KILL.
THEY MISSED HIM THERE.
>> Brian: HIS POSITIONING IS SO
GOOD, OF COURSE THAT'S WHY HE
DOESN'T BLOCK SO 40-YEAR-OLD.
HE WILL BE 41 IN MAY.
HERE IS KUCHEROV.   BRIAN ELLIO
OLD.